sin muy buenos días desde lo major
efectivamente por primera vez en sus 75
años de historia la asamblea general se
celebrará de manera virtual y ninguno de
esos 90 193 jefes de estado viajarán
aquí a nueva york por las restricciones
de cuarentena impuestas en medio de esta
pandemia las intervenciones serán de
manera virtual con discursos pregrabados
que rondarán los 15 minutos de duración
y solamente un representante por país
estará permitido entrar en la sala en
ese hemiciclo y por supuesto en medio de
fuertes medidas sanitarias como son este
distanciamiento social o el uso
obligatorio de mascarillas una parte
importante que se va a perder este año
son estas reuniones entre mandatarios de
esos esos almuerzos esas cenas que
permiten a los mandatarios de todo el
mundo tratar temas de suma importancia a
la parte buena es que este formato
virtual ha hecho que participen más jefe
de estados que nunca a 171 en total este
año como decías el tema central por
supuesto hacer alcohol 19 y cómo se va a
trabajar para construir un mundo post
pandemia unificado igualitaria
en el que se apueste por preservar el
medio ambiente erradicar la pobreza y
conseguir esa igualdad de género muy
importante también será la constitución
de la vacuna la que guterres ha dicho
que se trata de un bien público y no de
una herramienta electoral bueno en los
discursos arrancan mañana pero hoy se
celebra el aniversario 75 de la asamblea
cuéntenos a qué hora está previsto que
comience
y un 75 cumpleaños que se va a celebrar
de nuevo por esta pandemia en medio de
una austeridad espera se espera que
arranque hoy a las 9 de la mañana con la
intervención en persona del recién
nombrado presidente de la asamblea
general el representante por turquía
volkan voz y seguido del secretario
general de las naciones unidas y por
supuesto la intervención de los
representantes de los estados miembros
de los estados observadores y de la
unión europea se espera que se lleve a
cabo una declaración en la que se
apueste por el multilateralismo en un
momento precisamente en el que el mundo
se encuentra tremendamente polarizado
por esta pandemia